it's not out of fashion
to put on a bulletproof jacket and a
ballistic helmet
it was an effort to secure my life
some more that is after i survived
gun attacks more than once more than
twice
i was targeted my car was riddled with
bullets flattening all tyres
and that one occasion the military shoot
into the windscreen of my car
miraculously i'm still alive and nobody
was shot dead
in my car however many of my close
allies have been shot dead
i have been targeted uh by tiago's
canisters
and life bullets every single person
that i've been moving with on the
campaign trail has been
partner has been hit from producer dan
magic who was hit by
with the tiago's canister splitting his
face to my close
ally and singing partner nobian lee was
shot on the head
to my personal security
who was targeted and shot on the eye and
a few days ago
my close journalist who was covering the
events around me
in the campaign trail who showed
directly in the head
smashing his skull and
part of his brain was exposed so
wearing a ballistic helmet and a
bulletproof vest
is an effort to secure my life the
election
is being stolen and rigged not will be
by the mere fact that i was arrested on
the day of nomination that have been
blocked from campaigns that my posters
are not allowed to be there that i'm not
allowed to have any billboards
that i'm blocked from radio and tv
stations that i'm a candidate
a presidential candidate who is not
allowed to drive on main roads
or to even to address people in towns
that's a rig but the mere fact that the
electoral commission has come out to
block me
just me from campaigning in more than 30
districts
and indeed the electoral commission said
i must sign a memorandum of
understanding with them
before they can allow me to proceed
campaigning while everybody else is
campaigning
by pretending to ban campaigns in
the most populated areas where we have
more than 45 percent of the voters
and yet genome 70 the incumbent
president continues to campaign
under the protection of police and
military by the harassment that
has been ongoing the mass murder that
has been carried out
by the police and the military by the
habitual arrest of 100
of my campaign team on the 30th of
november in kalangala island
and myself inclusive only that i was
seeing
singularity airlifted by the military
and
dumped and detained in my house by the
fact that
even when i came up with another
campaign team it was all rounded up
yesterday and arrested
that proves that the ground is not
leveled there's no free unfair fairness
freedom and fairness here
however we are going into this election
as a protest i have been calling upon
ugandans to come out
and vote this is our only opportunity we
are non-violent
so we're using this election as a
protest
to speak and speak loudly
the election is being stolen because the
military and the police
have taken over the duty of the
electoral commission
it is not the electoral commission that
is in charge it is the military
people are not allowed to use their
phones and cameras to record the
proceedings
the electoral commission just came out
recently and banned
journalists from covering the elections
this comes at the backdrop of
deporting very many
international journalists that had come
to cover the election
it comes at the backdrop of the european
union
being unable to come and uh watch this
election
however we know that we are 45 million
ugandans
and we ensured that we call upon people
to register massively we have
18 million voters when all these people
come out
and vote we are sure they will be able
to assert their voices
and that will change our country forever
we are going to get our freedom or we
shall die trying to get our freedom
good enough we are non-violent and we
are living in a generation where the
world is watching
our biggest weapon is the camera
exposing all the atrocities that are
being committed against the people of
uganda
yesterday i announced to the
international community
and to the world that we are petitioning
the international criminal court
to investigate genome 70 general elite
mini and
all these other security bosses
over the crimes against humanity that
continue
to be committed against the people of
uganda we know that all these efforts
will bear fruit one day
i live every day as if it's the last day
my life is threatened my the life of my
wife is threatened
my close allies and everybody that
associates with me
but we keep going knowing that our lives
do not end with us so many people have
already paid the ultimate price
and my life is not any much more
valuable than the lives of the people of
uganda
of course like anybody else i love
to live a long life but there comes a
time
when life is only life when it's lived
freely the united kingdom
and uganda have very close ties
we have historical ties but i also want
to believe that what binds us together
are the values that we share as the two
nations
values like the rule of law values like
respect to
human rights values like respect
and governing according to the
principles of democracy
these are values that we have called
upon all development partners
all allies of uganda regionally
continentally and internationally
to push our leaders to to remember that
they are not dealing with museveni
they're individual they're dealing with
merced
on the on behalf of the people of uganda
he's
76 also he says although we believe he's
much older
he's not going to live forever
we always appeal to them to
have their collaboration their
cooperation with the people of uganda
not most having as an individual and to
always
stand by the values that they profess
we always ask them to make a
precondition of
respect for democratic principles
respect for human rights and respect for
the rule of law
to make them preconditions for
cooperation with uganda
what we want to achieve from the
international criminal court first and
foremost is to send a message
to genome 70 that he is not above the
law that in the year 2021
no body can commit crimes against
humanity
and get away with it we want
those investigations and the findings
to hold the genome seven accountable
we are aware that there are plans
to commit mass crimes to commit mass
violence
there's a plan to kill so many people by
the military
and the police we want to send a message
to general mustafini
that the world is watching and for every
single crime that he commits
against humanity there will be
a day of recon there will be a day when
he will have to
answer for those crimes and to also send
a message
to all those that hold guns to know that
in this time and era no human being
must be subjected to human rights abuses
and to also send the message to the
dictators
all over the world that they
may take long to fall but they
eventually fall
one by one the uganda
we want to live in what we call a new
uganda
is a uganda where
there is sovereign leadership there's a
uganda
where the government is a
people-centered government a uganda
where everybody is equal before and
under
the law in uganda where the law protects
us the same
and punish us the same in uganda
where there's equal opportunity
for everybody equal access to employment
equal access to
quality education and quality health
care
for every ugandan regardless of their
second name or where
they come from or who they know in
uganda
where you know there's equitable
balanced um economic
development for everybody
where we don't just see those
in positions of authority throwing
around statistics
to explain economic growth but in real
sense
the masses the bulk of the population is
languishing
is suffering is sweating under the yoke
of poverty
you want to live in a uganda where
people
are not evicted from their land
by the rich and mighty in the armed
forces and in government
in uganda where um
want to live in uganda where um
[Music]
there is equal rights and justice where
then
the the um
natural resources of the country belong
to the citizens
not where you see the president saying
it's my oil
where the president
is having a brother that has taken over
all the gold in muvende
in uganda where the president gives
the gold and the natural resources and
the minerals of a certain region
to the wife as a
birthday gift we want to live in uganda
where the natural resources of the
country
benefit the citizens in uganda
where we are no longer a laughingstock
among nations
uganda that has healthy relations
with our neighbors with sister countries
where we don't have
to have borders closed on us in uganda
where we
are respected and upload on the
international platform
and not being known for poverty
for disease for corruption and for
dictatorship that's a uganda that i
envision that we envision
as a generation